es un fenómeno que durante mucho tiempo
ha irritado a los locales y suscitó el
debate denominados rodeos urbanos en
francia las acrobacias en moto se
originaron en eeuu en barrios de bajos
ingresos predominantemente minoritarios
y con pocos lugares recreativos desde
entonces se ha convertido en parte de
muchas culturas urbanas pero aunque el
público francés está cada vez más
consciente de esta práctica eso no
significa que esté en auge
yo lo creo sinceramente que este
crecimiento mismo lo que está creciendo
es la cobertura mediática
las discusiones y el ruido sobre esta
práctica
en las últimas semanas los rodeos
urbanos han dejado a varios niños
heridos y un motociclista de 19 años
murió un joven afgano también falleció
tras protestar contra la práctica el
ministro del interior francés de
halderman pidió que se tomen medidas
dijo esta semana que las autoridades
confiscaron 1800 cutters y motos y
tuvieron más mil personas desde
principios de este año la policía
francesa señala a los motociclistas de
provocación
han provocado a la policía también
durante mucho tiempo los rodeos se
celebraban en su mayoría lejos de zonas
urbanas pero ahora se acercan más en las
ciudades porque quieren ser provocadores
para presumir en 2018 frank se convirtió
los rodeos urbanos en un delito punible
con hasta 5 años de prisión y decenas de
miles de euros en multas